OUT OF HARMS WAY.
HE BACKED INTO THE FLYERS WHO
ARE AFTER THE PUCK AND BACK TO
FULL STRENGTH.
DUMOULIN IS THE DEFENSEMAN THAT
GETS IT AHEAD.
BLUEGER GOES AND GETS IT
HE WAS CHECKED.
THE PUCK SITTING IN THE CIRCLE.
BLUEGER WINNING THE BATTLE.
MARINO AND KAPANEN WITH THE
SHOT.
STOPPED BY LYON . NOW IT'S A
WHISTLE.
THEY COME OUT AND THE WHISTLE
BLOWS. THE REFEREE SIGNALING IT
DID NOT CROSS THE LINE.
THE FACE-OFF WILL BE IN THE
FLYERS ZONE.
LYON ABLE TO REACH BACK AND USE
EVERY INCH OF HIS REACH TO KEEP
THAT OUT OF THE NET.
>> Keith: THE STICK BLEW OUT OF
HIS HANDS WITH THAT SHOT ON THE
SCREEN.
WATCH THE SECOND EFFORT BY
LYON.
RIGHT AT THE LINE HE GETS THE
BLOCKER ON IT.
GOOD HELP I BRAUN RIGHT AFTER
THAT.
KAPANEN'S SHOT GOES OFF THE
BLOCKER OF LYON.
THAT BLOCKER COMES IN HANDY.
A COUPLE FINGERS ON THE PUCK
AND IT KEEPS IT FROM GOING
ACROSS THE LINE.
GREAT SECOND EFFORT BY ALEX
LYON.
ZUCKER